emmenez-nous faire le tour
Canisius a atterri bonjour je suis
Meredith Vickers et c'est mon travail de
m'assurer que vous faites bien le vôtre, puis avec le
spectacle ce sont des images de
fouilles archéologiques partout sur la terre des
civilisations anciennes qui ne partageaient aucun contact et
pourtant le  même pictogramme dans chaque dernier
c'est une carte des étoiles
non je ne suis pas une invitation pour la lune
c'est amaura et vous trouvez ces
rayons là-bas
vous ne les engagerez pas vous ne leur parlerez
pas je ne ferai rien je ferai rapport à  moi,
mademoiselle Vickers, y a-t-il un ordre du jour dont
vous ne nous dites pas
jusqu'où iriez-vous pour obtenir vos réponses,
regardez ce
précédent tout ce que vous dites, ils avaient
raison,
vous voulez qu'il se trompe de viol, voici le
terrain par femme que James a ramassé  beaucoup
de plein elle a une épingle mais qu'est-ce que tu
vas payer tu vas là-bas vas-
tu
mourir  revenir vers
toi